vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons
la liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes c'est diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même
bienvenue sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire les élections
présidentielles américaines c'est mardi
prochain le 3 novembre nous saurons
bientôt si donald trump va rempiler pour
un second mandat aussi joe biden va lui
succéder en janvier
c'est donc le moment de faire un bilan
du mandat de donald trump à la maison
blanche
sur le plan intérieur et sur le plan
extérieur pour en débattre nous avons
invité jean luc hess ancien
correspondant de france inter à
washington en 2008 c'est pour charlie
hebdo que vous avez suivi l'élection
présidentielle américaine avant de
devenir le président de radio france de
2009 à 2014
aujourd'hui vous êtes président du
comité d'éthique de la chaîne arte
france et vous publier un nouveau livre
sur les états unis
intitulée l'amérique la facture c'est
sur le déclin de l'influencé américaine
dans le monde c'est paru aux éditions
baker street jean luc hess le bilan de
donald trump à vos yeux plutôt positif
ou plutôt négatif
ben vu le titre du bouquin ce serait
plutôt négatif même complètement négatif
c'est le titanic
je vous conseille de lire d'ailleurs
simplement le l'éditorial de théâtre
antique excellente revue politique
presque 200 ans aux états unis vous
diront que c'était le pire président des
états unis depuis la création du pays
la naissance de la nation je suis assez
d'accord avec eux edouard husson vous
êtes historien vous avez dirigé
l'european business school vous avez été
vice président de l'université paris
sciences et lettres vous êtes à présent
professeur à l'institut franco allemand
d'études européennes à l'université de
cergy pontoise
pour vous quel bilan écoutez c'est bien
il va y avoir du départ puisque moi je
pense que c'est le meilleur président
américain depuis ronald reagan
je me prononcerai pas sur les
présidences d'avant et j'aurai des
raisons de le montrer tout à l'heure à
la remplit intérieur et en politique
extérieure
didier combo vous êtes politologue
spécialisé dans les états unis chercheur
associé à l'institut des amériques vous
êtes l'auteur de être américain
aujourd'hui les enjeux d'une élection
présidentielle qui vient de paraître
chez gallimard
quel bilan vous vous tirez de ce mandat
écoutez tout dépend du
bonneville qui on se place bien entendu
ce qu'on peut constater ce qui est
certain c'est qu'il a accentué les
fractures et la polarisation de la
société américaine il a beaucoup utilisé
cette polarisation pour se faire élire
et une fois élu
on n'a pas l'impression qu'il est
vraiment cherché à être le président de
tous les américains
enfin le quatrième c'est nicolas
goetzmann qui est économiste et les
mêmes chef économiste de la financière
de la cité quel bilan pour vous nicolas
sur le plan sur le plan économique on va
dire que c'est plutôt positif
on a une administration trump je pense
que là où c'est intéressant c'est de
voir que on a une administration qui
encore une fois une espèce de
technocratie américaine qui a réussi à
se réveiller grâce au monde at donald
trump et qui a permis un band à un
mandat assez positif je propose de
commencer ce débat pas la politique
étrangère après tout c'est elle qui nous
concerne le plus concert en ce qui
concerne donald trump
alors vous parlez dans votre livre jean
luc hess de perte d'influencé des états
unis c'est à settat donald trump que
vous que cela incombe à votre avis de
l'atome c'est juste le symptôme de
quelque chose qui va pas aussi bien
politique et que c'est à dire que quand
je ne sais pas lui qui a entamé cette
espèce de désengagement des les
américains mais ce que ce que je pense
profondément et depuis très très très
très longtemps c'est que l'amérique est
une nation particulière
elle a un destin particulier c'est la
première puissance mondiale encore à ce
jour est donc à la des responsabilités
particulières
donc voilà il faut il faut qu'elle les
assume
or j'ai l'impression et pas seulement
l'impression que donald femme n'a pas
compris justement la pertinence de son
mandat c'est à dire je pense qu'il n'a
pas de vision globale de de la
complexité de la planète je pense qu'il
n'a aucun sens des responsabilités je
pense qu'il sait pas traiter ses alliés
correctement ce qui est quand même le
minimum ce sont des vieilles alliances
se dire entre la france et les etats
unis c'est pas simplement le marquis de
la fayette
ces deux guerres que les américains sont
venus livrer sur notre sol d'autres
territoires donc pardonnez moi j'ai un
attachement très profond pour l'amérique
et pour l'idée que je me fais de
l'amérique et je pense que l'amérique
est une idée est que donald trump n'a
pas respecté cette idée par ignorance
par incompétence par le narcissisme j'ai
arrêté parce que je n'aille pas être un
poil objectif quand on en vient cet
individu mais on n'a pas besoin d'être
objectif dans cette émission réajusta
débat edouard husson en plus et là pour
dire le contraire de ce que vous venez
de dire
imagine donc alors justement l'amérique
at-elle attelle
encore des alliés ou plutôt at elle
choisi d'avoir encore des alliés parce
que c'est un des reproches qu'on fait
donald trump d'avoir négligé l'otan et
ses alliés
alors ce que veut dire jurica c'est
extrêmement intéressant parce que je
crois qu'effectivement c'est pas la
question d'être objectif ou pas ou de de
débattre ou pas avec des points de vue
opposés jeudi à même c'est très sain
d'avoir des points de vue différents et
moi si vous voulez pour moi l'amérique
ce n'est pas une idée c'est d'abord une
nation c'est l'une de ses plus grandes
nations démocratiques du monde du point
de vue de je dirais de son rayonnement
jeu et donc à partir de là je pense que
le le grand problème qui existait sous
l'ère obama et et des années qui avaient
précédé c'était que on assistait à ce
que christopher la chapelle la sécession
des élites et le danger de détachement
des élites du reste de la nation
américaine avec tout ce que ça
impliquait ses élites pensait que elle
vivait dans un monde global e globalisé
mondialisé et hisse en ce sens préoccupé
finalement de savoir si c'était bon ou
mauvais pour le peuple américain hillary
clinton en 2016 représente elle a
vraiment le l'apogée de ceux de ce
sentiment en fait de cette indifférence
vis-à-vis du peuple américain
c'est la raison pour laquelle je pense
que ce que trame fait est très compliqué
il le fait de mon point de vue avec un
une certaine réussite c'est à dire qu'il
faut à la fois accroché là le reste de
la nation américaine à une politique
étrangère
elles comprennent et en même temps il
faut que la que les états unis
recommence à peser dans le monde parce
que je crois qu'il a pris la mesure de
l'un déclin de l'influencé américaine et
si j'avais une chose à dire c'est que
moi comme français comme européen je le
remercie d'avoir posé la question de de
la chine et du rapport de force avec la
chine c'est le premier président
américain qui rétablit un rapport de
force favorable à l'occident vis-à-vis
de la chine
oui didier combo qu'en pense-t-il
toujours sur le plan de la politique
étrangère et surtout alors on va revenir
sur sur l'est sur la chine mais mais
plus particulièrement
donald trump vis-à-vis de saint vallier
vie david le temps deux d'entre eux a
suivi une politique très isolationniste
le retrait d'un certain nombre d'accords
d'accord nucléaire avec l'iran les
accords de paris il a voulu mais c'était
son programme donc on peut difficilement
lui reprocher faire passer les intérêts
américains avant le les intérêts
internationaux et est est-ce qu'il faut
lui reprocher c'est pour cela qu'il a
été élu donc ou du conte qu'il a fait il
a fait ce qu'on attendait de lui et le
[Musique]
il a été beaucoup critiquée à l'étranger
effectivement tout particulièrement en
france
mais son point de vue c'est amérique
afrique
nicolas geissmann à on a un problème
avec un problème technique avec nicolas
lots restants sur sur la sur les skis
vient d'être abordée par didier combo on
a beaucoup polémiqué autour de la
décision de donald trump de se retirer
de l'accord avec l'iran de prendre de
reconnaître jérusalem comme la capitale
de l'état d'israël son plan de paix
aussi israélo-palestinien suscité pas
mal de polémiques
tout cela vous le mettez à son crédit
edouard husson
il a eu raison de faire tout ça ça a
marché je crois est effectivement je
crois que d'abord on mesure la réussite
d'un président à ce qu'il avait annoncé
qu'il ferait et donald trump est le
premier président américain depuis
longtemps qu'il fait qui fait ce qu'il
avait annoncé alors on peut ensuite ne
pas aimer cette politique mais moi je
considère que c'est quelque chose qui
peut réconcilier les citoyens avec la
politique et c'est roja dans nos nations
européennes d'avoir un chef de l'état
qui fait exactement ce qu'ils avaient ce
qu'il avait promis
c'est la première chose la deuxième
chose c'est que si vous voulez regardons
le ce qui s'est passé sur le temps
donald trump a fait exactement en fait
le même constat que barack obama à
savoir que la contribution des alliés
des etats-unis au sein de l'otan était
trop faible il a demandé qu'elles
augmentent
obama avait dit la même chose mais ça
n'avait pas été suivi pour moi qui suit
les affaires allemandes
je constate que l'allemagne a augmenté
son budget
la défense sous la pression de donald
trump donc c'est à ça que je mesure son
efficacité jean luc est déjà sur le
première partie de votre propos que je
respecte absolument mais vous savez un
certain adolf hitler il a fait ce qu'il
avait dit qu'il ferait je veux dire
c'est pas forcément une excellente chose
que quelqu'un d'un peu allumé pour dire
le moins je veille à mes propos mais ça
n'est pas forcément la meilleure façon
de réconcilier les citoyens avec avec
leurs élus mais bon voilà je suis là
elle est vraiment vécu les concernant
président et je démocratiquement le 30
août a fait écouter admettons choix
simple et on va dire mussolini ça vous
arrange puisqu'il n'arrête pas de citer
but celui des jeunes a complété un jeu
de la comparaison c'est moi qui décide
si elle tient ou pas et puis vous avez
un avis différent du dossier que
totalement non mais c'est sinon on peut
pas on peut pas débattre
vous admettrez que je peux ne pas dire
notamment
moi je suis là et ça me ça me semble une
insulte vis-à-vis d'impression
démocratique je m'appelle est-ce donc
j'ai certaines origines où je me permet
aussi de parler notamment sur c'est sur
ces choses là qui ont gâché toute ma vie
dont vous voyez on peut on peut ça
attire la soul et après je répète qu'il
ya un destin particulier de ce pays
américains et le ce destin c'est l'idée
encore une fois pardon c'est la nation
la plus démocratique du monde et j'aime
l'amérique profondément il se trouve
aussi que gouverner c'est avoir un style
qui n'est pas forcément de brutalité de
xénophobie d'ignorance d'incompétence je
pense que c'est le pire président que ce
pays ait connu et ça me fait un mal que
vous ne pouvez même pas soupçonner
probablement notamment quand il jure sur
la bible de lincoln et qui se compare à
lincoln voyez c'est juste le contraire
de ce qu'il faut faire je trouve ça
aussi instamment que les propos que je
viens de tenir si ça peut vous anges
mais alors revenons sur les faits didier
combo je parlais de l'iran je parlais de
de jérusalem du plan de paix
israélo-palestinien est ce que tout ça
est à mettre au crédit de 30 pour au
contraire ça s'est révélé plutôt négatif
c'est à dire que sans son point de vue
c'est un petit peu le le fait que la
force doit prévaloir en quelque sorte
qu'il reprochait un par exemple traiter
avec l'iran
c'était de ne pas être suffisamment
exigeants vis-à-vis qui vend et on peut
peut-être lui reprocher de manquer de
réalisme dans son approche de deux de
vouloir aller trop loin à haut risque de
na li mais nulle part dans dans ce genre
de questions et c est ça c'est couple
est quand même avec une volonté
d'isolationnisme de de s'occuper d'abord
des affaires américaines ce qui est une
tendance lourde aux états unis s'est il
ya cette double tendance à la fois de
guider le monde à la fois d'être un ps
un pays messianique des états unis tout
comme la france avec love revolution
avec leur le l'avènement de la
démocratie donc à la fois un pays
messianique et aussi un cri qui estime
que finalement ces intérêts doivent
passer d'abord que les états unis sont
un pays qui a mieux réussi que les
autres en termes de d'opportunités de
démocratie etc et que finalement il faut
pas les mêler des affaires du monde que
si si si le monde fonctionne mal les
états unis n'ont pas à s'en mêler
d'opiacés deux tendances et trump est un
peu d un peu des deux côtés parce qu'à
la fois il is isolationniste en se
retirant des traités internationaux mais
il est aussi très très partisan de la
force également donc c'est un petit peu
ambigu et là justement ce sur tous ces
sujets on a dit qu il
versez la table que c'était un
négociateur hors pair
edouard husson vous pensez que sur
l'iran sur jérusalem
il est bien fait il a il a remporté la
mise
et écoutez je pense d'abord qu'il faut
il faut voir qu'il ay là il est revenu à
une ligne qui dans le monde arabo
musulman favorable à l'iran plus
favorable au monde sunnite
donc ça c'est il ya une cohérence dans
sa politique est d'ailleurs joe biden à
l'opposé dit qu'il reviendra puis qui se
rapprochera de l'iran et il mettra un
bémol à la politique
donald trump vis-à-vis du monde sunnite
on revient à des options antérieure au
tournant de 2001 lorsque après le 11
septembre les mêmes les républicains
s'étaient éloignés de leurs liens forts
en partie en tout cas le lien fort avec
avec le monde sunnite avait joué avait
joué une carte chic donc grimper revenus
à des fondamentaux du parti républicain
c'est une chose
la deuxième chose c'est qu'effectivement
il a poussé certains très bien plus fort
et il confie même eu et ronald reagan
qui était dans le plus inspiré du sprint
mais avant avant lui et est donc que par
exemple il est allé beaucoup plus loin
sur la politique en faveur en faveur
d'israël
si on me demandait personnellement je
trouve c'est une bonne chose tout ce qui
soutient l'état d'israël me semble être
une très bonne chose
au-delà de ça ensuite je comprends qu'on
puisse en discuter et je ne suis pas sûr
alors là pour le coup pour apporter de
la nuance c'est pas parce que je dis que
le travail peuple est un très bon
président et qu' il a fait des choses
qui sont cohérentes
c'est pas pour autant que du point de
vue des intérêts européens je pense que
nous devions nous aligner sur tout par
exemple je suis plus sceptique sur le le
retour vers le monde sunnite au point où
il l'a fait mais voilà ensuite comme ça
a été dit à l'instant les états unis
sont une nation
elles ont leurs intérêts une nation
souveraine est effectivement la vision
de trappes
je vais alors je vais ajouter à la
provocation mais pour changer une
comparaison
quel que soit le style tram a une vision
très gaullienne des relations
internationales sur le jean luc hess
jean luc est au moyen-orient risque est
ce que là elle et les américains
renforcer leurs positions ou au
contraire ont continué de perdre du
terrain parce que ça a commencé
quasiment avec l'invasion de l'irak qui
s'est renversée qui n'a pas du tout
servi les intérêts américains
non mais là on évoquer mon cher général
de gaulle qui considérait que la région
était compliqué comme on disait et je
pense qu'il faut jamais les choses dc
les choses complexes dans des notes de
chant qui sont pas compétents qui n'ont
pas un sens de l'histoire et non pas
avec des idées ça tout à fait c'est pour
ça je faisais référence à vos derniers
propos ça m'ennuie beaucoup enfin je dis
moi je suis pas politologue loyer je
suis journaliste et j'ai beaucoup voyagé
dans ces régions et j'ai travaillé dix
ans aux etats-unis c'est un pays encore
une fois je précise toujours pour lequel
j'ai une profonde profonde affection
mais il me semble que si je devenais 45e
président des états unis je confierais
pas mon gendre qui n'y connaît pas
d'ailés mois que dalle à cette rien
mystérieux et compliquer la gestion
d'une affaire comme d'hab' et au proche
orient est une espèce de comment dire de
c'est pas un jouet c'est pas un jeu
c'est pas c'est sérieux c'est de la
diplomatie c'est sérieux il ya eu il ya
un drame qui dure depuis des décennies
et des décennies que dis-je une tragédie
et donc je ne peux pas m'empêcher de
penser quand je regarde le plan de paix
qui a été présenté par le gendre de
donald trump qui encore une fois n'y
connais pas grand chose et je regarde
attentivement ce plan j'essaye d'être
quelqu'un dessus journaliste donc
j'essaie de comprendre ce qui se passe
et je vois que bon voilà on oublie
l'histoire on va donner 10 milliards de
dollars à ses chers palestiniens qui
encore c'est pas les états unis qui les
deux noms bien sûr ce serait une
contribution internationale
un jour l'offre à un petit aéroport sur
un petit bout d'îles au large de la côte
pour qu'il puisse voyager comme tout le
monde je me dis c'est humiliant c'est
assez stupide et ça n'arrivera jamais et
ça va prolonger cette espèce de pas de
crise identitaire mais c'est cette
espèce d'impasse dans laquelle on vit
depuis que je suis née et vous aussi
monsieur donc j'ai du mal à comprendre
tout ça j'ai une plus haute idée
de ce qui se passe dans le bureau ovale
depuis 250 ans à peu près c'est on a une
responsabilité particulière quand on
occupe ce bureau et il faut être à la
hauteur de cette responsabilité et je le
sens comme ça depuis quatre ans et je
suis pas sûr que la planète se porte
mieux et que le monde soit plus sûr je
sais pas si pour vous par exemple ou vos
enfants ou vos proches vous vous dites
je vis dans un monde plus sûr
aujourd'hui il ya quatre ans moi j'ai
exactement le sentiment contraire je
peux me tromper
on va continuer le débat malheureusement
sur 100 marc bosman qui a dû nous
quitter on a un problème technique
nicolas pardon de goat man on a eu un
problème technique donc il n'est plus là
continuons sur on se souvient aussi d'un
rapport de force très dur entre entre
donald trump est le leader de la corée
du nord
là aussi est ce que est ce que donald
trump l'a emporté
à vous à vos yeux edouard husson je
pense que sur la corée du nord c'est le
c'est le domaine où il n'a pas n'a pas
obtenu les succès il l'escomptait jeu je
crois simplement s'ils voulaient que ça
vient d'un fait très simple c'est que la
corée du nord était soutenu par la chine
et que la grande partie en fait elle se
joue entre la chine et des états unis
et là je voudrais 1,6 et sur ce que je
disais tout à l'heure
effectivement on a un grand tournant en
temps les relations entre les etats-unis
et la chine sous tram et moi je peux
témoigner de quelque chose que j'ai vue
en direct
en fait en effectuant une longue visite
en chine à l'automne 2018 lorsque
effectivement en fait c'est avec des
rencontres avec un ensemble de
personnalités du pouvoir chinois
j'étais dans un groupe qui effectivement
effectué les rencontres à redire à
niveau intermédiaire mais c'était déjà
très intéressante et ce qui était
frappant c'est que les les français avec
lesquels j'étais arrivée en parlant avec
un certain une certaine distance voire
un mépris de donald trump et en face des
interlocuteurs chinois
membre du parti communiste business men
ou autre il répondait détrompez vous il
faut pas les sous-estimer
et pour nous c'est la perte de 0.5 de
croissance peut-être d'emprunt
croissance peut-être de 2 à terme alors
leur plaidoyer c'était en faveur de le
lien fort entre l'europe et et il à
chine
mais ce qui m'avait frappé à l'époque
c'était que les chinois prenait très au
sérieux de nike france et je crois que
ils le prennent aujourd'hui toujours
très au sérieux
c'est là qu'ils se jouent quelque chose
et effectivement je vais afficher d une
préférence personnelle c'est à dire que
je je pense moi je préfère un monde où
les les états unis et l'otan et compte
dans l' équilibre du monde face à une
chine est un état pour moi néo
totalitaire et dont je me méfie alors je
voudrais y jean luc hess le permet je
voudrais que la suite du débat se passe
avec une totale sérénité qu'on soit
d'accord sur un point je crois que
autour de cette table si j'ose dire pas
dans ce débat nous aimons tous beaucoup
les états unis c'est pour ça que nous
sommes là mais nous pouvons avoir des
visions divergent 2
manière dont les états unis sont
gouvernés l'acier 10 des combos sûr sûr
sûr le rapport avec la corée du nord et
ensuite on ira sur les rapports avec la
guerre commerciale avec la chine mais
d'abord un mot sur la sur la corée du
nord parce que ça a été assez
spectaculaire
il a mis beaucoup de lui même donald
trump dans cette affaire bilan il a
choisi là aussi la manière forte par
rapport à ce qui s'était fait auparavant
il ya quand même eu un certain succès
parce que il ya eu des rencontres et une
des choses qui se sont produites donc
pas considérer que ce soit complètement
négatif sur lukas un mot particulier sur
sur l'accord écrit ça pour moi c'est un
cas d'école parce que cette visite après
tout elle avait halal mérite d'avoir
existé et puis une personne ne se plaint
quand deux camps opposés c'est de se
raccrocher donc j'ai pas deux j'ai pas
de commentaires négatifs à faire
là-dessus mais je me mets à la place des
iraniens qui regarde cette visite
et puis finalement la corée du nord a
toujours sa bombinette où ces bombinette
je suis pas un expert dans la chose
militaire mais met donc on fait encore
quelques essais puis donc c'est ancré ça
veut dire que la corée du nord n'a
évidemment pas renoncer au nucléaire
militaire et du cou donald trump traite
son amie kim jong hoon plutôt bien c'est
un copain il lui écrit des lettres et
tous en face à ce coup ci ce qu'on
entend de temps en temps venant de la
maison blanche
et si je me mets dans la position
iranienne
je me dis mon dieu mais il faut que
j'aie une bombe atomique plus vite
possible et puis là on va on va me
respectent et en tout cas ne me touchera
pas on s'occupera pas de mes affaires
parce que pardon la corée du nord c'est
quand même une autocratie premières d'où
enfin un jeu d'erreurs on n'a encore
jamais vu ça c'est un monde de chou donc
je pense que c'est un encouragement à
tous les tous les autocrates tous les
régimes vraiment totalitaire à avoir le
plus vite possible une bombe atomique
comme ça on aura la paix avec donald
donald trump et ça me gêne beaucoup
nous parlions tout à l'heure de bonnes
références
un régal ils sont que j'ai passé 8 ans
huit années de ma vie fois avec ronald
reagan mais à côté de renard et gamme
puisque je t'ai correspondants
accrédités à la maison blanche et qu'à
l'époque c'était avant les twin towers
on entrait comme dans un moulin la
maison blanche donc on voyait assez
souvent le président ans et j'ai
beaucoup de respect beaucoup d estime
pour eux ce président archi républicains
conservateurs c'est moi qu'on puisse en
dire mais avec le style avec un style
qui correspond à l'image que nous aimons
de l'amérique c'est à dire une espèce de
décence de de tolérance de d'élégance
quoi on va appeler un chat un chat et je
pense que ça fait aussi du bien à
l'amérique
quand le locataire de la maison blanche
d'un homme élégant dans la manière dans
le style est donc dans l'expression de
ses idées c'était pour vous dire que
j'ai autant d'amis république jacques
damez démocrates aux états unis c'est
vrai juste une minute et edouard husson
avant qu'on fasse la pause mais c'est
vrai que en permanence on en revient à
l'apparence à la forme qu'a utilisée
donald trump pendant ces quatre années
de pouvoir
on a beaucoup de mal à se sortir de sa
vulgarité de tout ce qu'on lui reproche
fait au fond que vous ne l'avez pas
l'air de lui reprochez-vous non parce
que si vous voulez mais je n'ai pas à
juger du gip a jugé du style moi je me
rappelle je me rappelle que regan il
était au départ extrêmement critique
critique est vue comme manichéen on lui
reprocher sa rhétorique sur l' empire du
mal et puis effectivement finalement
c'est lui qui a eu l'intuition qu'il
fallait travailler avec norman chef
moi il me semble que si si donald trump
est réélu un deuxième mandat on pourrait
avoir des surprises avec des changements
de style donc non vous savez je pense
que on a on a tendance aussi toujours vu
la france à vouloir imposer un style au
président américain
oui john f kennedy était et est plus
élégant que donald trump si on veut y
aller par là bon mais pour moi c'est pas
le sujet le sujet c'est trump par
rapport au peuple américain
on peut dire mauvais style regarder son
compte twitter et c'est très bien mais
s'il n'avait pas son compte twitter il
aura été écrabouillé par les médias
coalisés contre lui donc il ya un enjeu
qui est la crise de la démocratie qu'est
le fait que effectivement je parlais
j'insistais qu'est parce que moi j'y
tiens beaucoup
la thèse de christopher lasch sur la
cession des élites qu'on a vu se
réaliser le plus en plus avec clinton
bush et obama et ben trump veut revenir
là dessus
alors eh oui les populistes au départ il
parle au peuple aimé mais en même temps
il a quand même réussi à souder le parti
républicain était loin de lui être
acquis autour de lui et moi je juge un
politique à sa réussite
ensuite mauvais style oui je vous le
concède mais pour moi c'est secondaire
on fait une pause on se retrouve juste
après on abordera la politique
intérieure américaine
et puis évidemment la guerre commerciale
avec la chine
[Musique]
qui de haydn ou de trump a le programme
le plus à même de redresser le pays
quand vous dites à un américain qui va
être taxés plus ils voient rouge
ils pencheront plus tôt pour ceux qui
leur chante une jolie chanson comme quoi
les impôts n'augmenteront pas les
contours du programme de donald trump
sont quand même assez floue on pour
autant c'est vraiment sur la fiscalité
que tout est fait pour vous à la veille
du confinement
le taux de chômage est tombé à 3 5% un
taux de chômage de plein emploi je peux
vous dire une chose c'est que le plein
emploi
juste avant le coc vive c'était une
blague votre avis sur ce plan de relance
de john adams ne dira rien on est en
train de raser gratis
au bout du compte une facture à régler
byden il sera sans doute probablement
aussi protectionniste est aussi agressif
sur le plan mondial
un train
la france oubliée c'est une rencontre
avec ces citoyens qui ne se résignent
pas à la fatalité
on est comme tout le monde même si on
n'est pas en appartement et hervé
grenelle sentiment qu'il faut à chaque
fois se battre ils vivent parfois au
bord des routes nationales pas forcément
loin de paris mais toujours loin de ceux
qui les dirigent
majorque mâcon il passe un tour de
tracts avec toute leur campagne
il faut savoir cherubini ferrante ils
ont le sentiment d'être des français de
seconde zone comme s'ils étaient
invisibles
marc pourrait t'aider quoi un peu plus
aujourd'hui la france oubliée c'est
montrer ce qu'on ne voit jamais
[Musique]
on continue ce débat sur le bilan de
donald trump avec jean luc hees qui est
journaliste et qui publie l'amérique la
facture avec edouard husson qui est
historien avec didier combos que les
politologues et qu'il eut publié être
américain aujourd'hui les enjeux d'une
élection aux éditions gallimard
alors reprenons à partir de de cette
guerre commerciale avec la chine didier
combo est ce que qu'elles ont été les
effets sur les américains justement y
ont-ils gagné quelque chose à ce rapport
de force
instaurée avec un énorme concurrence sur
le plan économique qu'elle affine
aujourd'hui donald trump s'est fait
élire sur la défense des travailleurs
américains qui étaient victimes de
délocalisations et donc il a mis en
oeuvre est effectivement un rapport de
force avec la chine des droits de douane
qui qui avait pour objet de protéger
l'industrie américaine et ça je pense
que certains certains cols bleus
certains zones l'an cols bleus peuvent
peuvent lui en savoir gré des effets
économiques je suis pas un spécialiste
pour pouvoir leur parler mais il est
certain que ça correspondait à ce que
est ce que certains de ces électeurs
désiré et dans les fonds
yahia s'il ya un succès relatif mais
real avec avant le avant le vide devant
l'atletico vie de la création d'environ
500 mille emplois là je prends l'exemple
du industriels manufacturiers qui montre
un certain effet delà de la politique
effectivement mais si vous voulez le on
est vraiment dans la problématique une
démocratie avec à une élection tous les
quatre ans je pense que là la politique
de travaux visent à vis de la chine et
le retour de l'enfant industriel malgré
ses premiers succès
ne peut porter ne peut porter que sur le
temps long j'ajoute aussitôt que je
pense que le grand acquis de cette
politique de tram c'est que son
successeur aura aurait beaucoup de mal à
revenir dessus
il n'y aurait pas ce que je suis
convaincu qu'en fait déjà six et c'est
le parti démocratique et bayonne quelles
que soient les compromissions des
démocrates dans l'est dans les 15-20
dernières années avec le avec les avec
la chine écrit au jour il ya un nouveau
climat qui a été créée il ya une guerre
commerciale que vous disiez mais il ya
aussi le sentiment qu'il faut recréer
l'emploi industriel en amérique et de
même qu'on pourrait trouver si l'on
cherchait bien derrière les apparences
beaucoup plus de continuité entre le
lait mandat d'obama et ceux dont on
trouve et de la continuité avec un
nouveau mandat démocrate jean luc f
je suis d'accord avec ça j'ai d'abord on
peut pas reprocher à donald l'homme de
préserver les intérêts de son pays et
qu'il était peut-être temps aussi
d'accentuer la pression sur la chine
donc ça je n'ai aucun souci et sabote
c'est vrai que ça s'inscrit dans une
politique qui date déjà d'obama et je
pense pas que joe biden va aller montrer
s'il est élu à démontrer aux électeurs
américains parce que il y aura aussi des
gouvernés tous les américains passent à
3 et les électeurs qui ont voté pour lui
il va pas se précipiter chez chez le
président chinois pour lui faire des
mamours donc je comprends tout à fait ça
ce qui m'ennuie c'est que d'abord je
suis pas sûr que ça allait tellement
profité aux amériques a cédé aux
travailleurs américains ou aux
agriculteurs américains faudra voir le
temps long je suis d'accord avec ça mais
je pense surtout que ça permet à la
chine au gouvernement chinois de comment
dire de passer pour des gens plus
diplomate plus policé plus civilisée que
leurs homologues américains et ça leur
permet aussi de vrais mandat d'accroître
leur influence dans des réseaux on l'a
vu justement parlé du las d'épidémie
1019 salaire ça leur permet de passer
pour des gens un peu plus civilisée un
peu moins brutaux que les états unis et
franchement 2
d'augmenter leur influence dans les
organisations internationales ce qui me
dérange d'ailleurs un petit peu parce
que j'ai l'impression que c'est un
trafic d influence qui peut se révéler
pernicieux l usage mais voilà ils
passent tous des gens je dis encore une
fois ce qui est quand même étonnant une
vieille civilisation la chimie pour
davantage police et on peut faire plus
on peut faire plus confiance aux chinois
filiale manqué la brutalité de
l'amérique actuelle et je pense que si
on met les deux choses là où c'est fait
que jean luc est telle qu'on peut avoir
peut-être un petit déséquilibre qui est
pas favorable pour mes chers états-unis
et lé la sortie de l'accord de paris
edouard husson il a bien fait de la
halle trump est encore de quitter ce
traité sur le dérèglement climatique
nous avons c'est une position
personnelle que j'exprime je suis
extrêmement dubitatifs sur les
politiques écologiques définies dans les
sommets internationaux
pour moi les grands les politiques
écologiques de demain
ce sont des politiques ont fait
confiance à l'initiative des acteurs
locaux où on est en mesure effectivement
de de laisser beaucoup d'initiatives des
nouveaux secteurs industriels industrie
etc
donc j'ai pas une affection à considérer
pour les accords de paris et jeux ça m'a
pas autant affoler que les états unis en
sorte parce que je pense que derrière
tout ça et d'air ses objectifs et a
énormément d hypocrisie dans le système
international
mais j'avoue que là j'ai un point de vue
personnel et peut-être un peu en
décalage des enjeux et des combos sur le
plan écologique en général donald trump
on a vu qu'il avait pas grand respect
pour pour lé lé grand canyon par exemple
comme on le voit les américains là
encore le y est en phase avec son
électorale les conservateurs américains
sont d'une manière générale
opposé à un gouvernement centralisé aux
états unis mais main ils sont ils sont
favorables au droit des états par
rapport au droit du gouvernement fédéral
et ils sont encore moins favorables aux
accords internationaux et les problèmes
auxquels on fait face à l'heure actuelle
les questions d'environnement sont des
problèmes mondiaux où on a eu les pluies
acides qui ne connaissent pas les
frontières on a maintenant de
réchauffement climatique qui l'a aussi
n'est pas un problème local donc ce sont
des problèmes qui ne peuvent être réglés
qu'à un niveau supranational et sa
niveau supranational dans ce domaine là
comme dans d'autres les conservateurs
sont très très réticent à à le laisser
prendre de l'ampleur et est donc c'est
une forme encore une fois
d'isolationnisme mais pas seulement
c'est aussi c'est aussi en lien avec la
création des états unis qui sont une
union d'états des états unis sont locaux
par essence le gouvernement centralisé
fédéral c'est quelque chose qui est
assez balles admis par les conservateurs
et par les libertariens et autres et
encore et c'est encore pire lorsqu'il
s'agit de toute forme de gouvernement
supranational et que et en plus quand
cela s'ajoute qu'il ya des ddd
contraintes économiques
c'était le cas avec avec le l'accord de
paris bien sûr entre le lorsque
il faut faire le choix entre le réalisme
économique et les impératifs
environnementaux
donald trump a tendance à choisir les
les questions économiques comme on l'a
vu avec le pipe line qui stone xl et
d'autres projets alors maintenant au sol
sur le plan intérieur aux états unis je
reste un instant encore avec vous didier
combo là on al'impression vu de france
l'accès et c'est extrêmement dur si avec
les pros trump entre les pro et les anti
trump avec tout ce qui est minorité on a
l'impression que trump a été en gros le
président des blancs contre les autres
et même des hommes blancs mais c'est pas
forcément vrai c'est peut-être une
impression que nous avons nous dit si en
tout cas tout c'est terriblement durci
même si dans votre livre vous fait
remarquer que c'était beaucoup plus
violents avant notamment à la fin des
années 60 du temps de dixon au moment de
la guerre du vietnam ou là quand les
faits les policiers tirer dans la foule
il y avait beaucoup plus de morts
qu'aujourd'hui montfort impressionne
tout est très tendue alors est ce que
vous le confirmer est ce que dans le
bilan ce qu'on peut faire de ca détrempe
ce serait ça qui serait dans le négatif
d'ailleurs que l'amérique est plus
divisé que jamais oui l'amérique est
effectivement moins violente que jamais
on a vu les taux d'homicides qui ont
beaucoup baissé depuis là depuis la fin
du xxème siècle effectivement les
manifestations il ya beaucoup moins de
beaucoup moins or aujourd'hui que dans
les années 60 mais l'amérique est de
plus en plus petit v en revanche les
études montrent lorsque l'on questionne
les les
les démocrates et les républicains sur
des grandes questions de société
on s'aperçoit que les démocrates sont
plus à gauche aujourd'hui et les
républicains plus à droite c'est une
tendance qui a commencé avant train ce
sondage dont je vous parle ont constaté
en 2014 que que le gouffre s'étaient
créés depuis
depuis le début du xxième siècle donc
troubles exploités mais il n'a pas créé
et on peut dire qu'il l'a qu'il a attisé
7 ces différences d'une certaine manière
et qu'effectivement on peut estimer
qu'il s'est fait élire en tant que
président des blancs ce qui est ce qui
est nouveau tous les présidents avant
obama était blanc mais il était blanc en
quelque sorte parce qu'ils étaient
blancs et que le lait blanc domine et
associés mais il ne se faisait pas il
entend que blanc est ce que reprochent
certains afro-américains tron c'est
effectivement de cette fait dire en tant
que blanc on se souvient de la campagne
des pôles chose de don't run faisait
partie qui étaient les gens qui
contestait la légitimité d'obama parce
qu'il ne serait pas né américain ce qui
était faux et où il est si je me trompe
était né à hawaï qui était un état
américain à l'époque de sa naissance
donc c'était quelqu'un qui était
effectivement né sur le territoire
américain et et américains et qui donc
pouvait être président et donc on voit
que par ce type de prise de position il
ya quand même une dimension raciale et
de la rue font alors je crois qu'on est
né passe à des questions compliquées
effectivement ans des décombres a raison
de souligner ce paradoxe qui est que les
états unis sont moins violents et qu'il
ils l'ont été à des décennies
je voudrais simplement pour nuancer ce
qui vient des dits solides et que les
intentions de vote
actuellement sont très intéressantes on
s'aperçoit que alors que toi pas eu si
je ne me trompe pas 8 % de votes de
l'électorat noir e en 2016 les
intentions de vote sont aujourd'hui à
20% ce qui est considérable comme
augmentation et d'autre part dans
l'électorat hispanique
il y à un passage de peu plus de 35% de
vote effectifs en 2016 a pas loin de 50
% dans les intentions de vote dans les
sondages donc je pense que la question
est plus compliqué et là où je
suis aussi un petit peu dubitatif c'est
que il ya évidemment une tendance
naturelle dans la politique américaine à
à mettre en catégorie les noirs les
hispaniques que les blancs etc
je suis pas sûr que non français avec
notre idéal universaliste on s'y
retrouve toujours très bien
en tout cas les sondages je vous cite
hélas il s'agit d' intentions pas on
verra bien mardi prochain mais montre
que le tableau est plus nuancé que ce
qui vient d'être dit jean luc hess vous
avez l'impression que donald trump a
contribué à diviser l'amérique ou au
contraire elle hilare et considéré
puisque même les noirs et les latinos
aujourd'hui votre est massivement pour
lui alors il n'a pas dit mot sinon je
dis moi oui je pense que de père en fils
dans la famille on est raciste mais plus
s'il ya quoi que ça regarde après touché
j'ai peut-être tort et c'est une
accusation grave mais fondée
manifestement on l'a vu à usage mais qui
mène vous avez raison de dire que c'est
quelque chose d'extraordinairement
compliqué on peut pas il n'ya pas y'a
pas de vérités toutes faites là dessus
chez lui une très intéressante étude de
l'université de chicago je crois et qui
explique qu'ils montrent à quel point
trump qui a quelques défauts selon moi
mais il n'a pas que des défauts et c'est
un homme extrêmement rouet et qui a un
instinct d'ailleurs x en fait tout le
temps mais je pense qu'on peut lui
reconnaître cei là il est un as tu es
quand on parle je m'écarte un peu de des
problèmes raciaux aux états unis ça date
pas d'hier et ses patronnes qui les a
créées tram c'est un symptôme de quelque
chose mais c'est pas lui on peut pas lui
reprocher qui est des problèmes
interraciaux aux états unis mais cette
étude pour en revenir à ça de de
l'université de chicago traité de
quelque chose que tu chopes a
immédiatement compris je pense quand il
a songé à se présenter à la candidature
suprême aux etats unis c'est que aux
états unis vous avez des gens qui vont
très bien il y en a à peu près un tiers
sont des gens compte que cette étude de
qualifier de protéger nous dirait en
france aujourd'hui connectés
sont des gens qui ont fait de bonnes
études qui ont de bons revenus qui ont
une bonne famille qui les aident bien
ils ont un réseau social familial
professionnel ce qui fait que bon s'ils
ont un problème ils vont se débrouiller
et puis cette étude était paru pendant
enfin l'arrivée de la pandémie due
coronavirus est noté quelque chose de
vraiment que j'ai trouvé très important
qui m'a aidé à comprendre donald trump
vous voyez comme quoi il faut faire des
efforts pour comprendre de temps en
temps ça voulait dire que le virus était
une nuisance pour ce tir la d'américains
mais pour les deux tiers d'américains
qui sont pas protégés qui sont pas
connectés qui sont pas assez éduqués qui
n'ont pas des gros salaires qui sont
obligés d'aller travailler quand y'a le
virus et qui risquent leur vie en
faisant ça alors là c'est différent et
donc il ya 30 ans à surfer sur ce sur ce
malaise il ne l'a pas créé ce magasin la
précaution de dire ça mais il a réussi à
surfer sur cette espèce de divorce qui a
un truc ce que lui appelle les élites ce
qui est idiot puisque les élites après
tous ces cours vont mieux faire partie
de l'élite que pas faire partie de
l'élite quand on est petit on vous dit
ça ou disent tu travailles bien récolte
tu seras peut-être parmi les élites
c'est pas c'est pas une insulte d'être
dans les élus dans notre cas partie des
élites eric pas mais je crois qu'il a
réussi à surfer à lobotomiser un peu le
mot est un peu fort mais une partie
d'une grande partie de l'opinion il ya
63 millions d'américains combos et
donald trump il ya quatre ans donc c'est
pas tous des imbéciles des crétins
d'hérens idées xénophobes et les gens
passent il a saisi sa et au fond ce
qu'il faut retenir de trump et on verra
ce qui se passe le 3 novembre mais c'est
que l'amérique est pas en forme
l'amérique est pas en forme moralement
psychologiquement politiquement
démocratiquement racialement
économiquement il ya tout un tas de
problèmes qui font que on a vu ça
auparavant je pars faire de comparaison
avec l'histoire du siècle passé mais on
a déjà vu ce phénomène prospérer et ce
qui m'inquiète encore un peu plus c'est
que ça fait des petits et pas seulement
aux états unis c'est pour ça que je
pense que nous sommes tous américains
c'est que ce qui se passe aux etats unis
nous concerne directement et a des
conséquences directement et je pense par
exemple que des questions les gîtes
évidemment que se sont posée les
électeurs américains en 2016 et en
répondant comme l'îlot répondu en
élisant démocratiquement donald trump
on va se déposer nous chez nous en 2022
et donc je pense que la réussite de
trump pendant ces quatre ans cette
réussite populiste aura des conséquences
extrêmement importante pour nous
français mais comme ça on a eu pour les
brésiliens comme ça dans un projet
hongrois est comme si on a pour les
turcs des décombres si on doit conclure
là quelques jours de delà de l'élection
ces quatre années 30 s'il y en a pas
quatre 4 autres
qu'est ce qu'on en dira historiquement à
votre avis alors ça c'est on laissera
les historiens en juger mais il ya une
chose dont on n'a pas parlé c'est le les
dominations par trump de juges fédéraux
de je crois que l'héritage essentiel de
trump ce sera les juges fédéraux qu'il a
pu qu'il a pu nommer puisque il y à 25%
des juges des yeux l'édiction inférieur
qui ont été nommés par trump 205 juge
sur les puissants et quelques et puis il
a donné trois juges à la cour suprême
sur les neuf la cour suprême est
maintenant très clairement conservatrice
et ça c'est quelque chose qui aura un
effet pendant très longtemps puisque
tous ceux qui sont nommés à vie et donc
il y aura là je crois que ce sera
l'héritage essentiel de trump 7
on sait qu'aux états unis tout à l'heure
j'ai parlé de la polarisation entre les
deux parties cette polarisation est
tellement grande que il est difficile de
faire adopter des textes dits partisans
au congrès et que finalement ça ça donne
plus de pouvoirs au système judiciaire
puisque les activistes vont se tourner
vers le système judiciaire plutôt que
d'essayer de faire adopter des lois qui
ne parviendront de toute façon pas à
faire adopter donc cette cette
nomination des juges fédéraux c'est
c'est quelque chose qui est extrêmement
pur
pour les décennies à venir c'est
d'autant plus drôle ce que vous dites
que c'est que dans toutes les séries
américaines qui se passe notamment à la
maison blanche et il y en a de plus en
plus on voit en permanence le président
dire ben voilà comment on va faire pour
faire adopter cette loi en allant
chercher dans le parti adverse des gens
qui vont bien vouloir la beauté et
éventuellement même en leur offrant
quelques prébendes pour qu'ils acceptent
de la voter donc en fait tout ça c'est
de la fiction ça arrive de moins en
moins en réalité ça existe toujours bien
sûr mais c'est de plus en plus difficile
d'autant plus qu' il y à un système
d'obstruction au sénat qui fait que très
souvent il faut obtenir 60% des voix au
sénat pauvres il fait parvenir à faire
adopter un texte et un petit point
également qu'on n'a pas abordé c'est la
question de qui est qui est assez
central dans la question des relations
interraciales qui est la réforme de la
justice criminelle
et c'est quelque chose qu'il faut mettre
au crédit de train d'avoir des parvenus
à faire adopter
justement une loi pour le coup sûr
bipartisane d'ailleurs sur la réforme du
système criminel qui a permis de réduire
les peines planchers de réduire des
peines au moment des récidives et ça
c'est très important dans la question
interraciales puisque dans cette
incarcération de masse qui existe aux
états unis elles concernent beaucoup
plus les afro-américains que le reste de
la population
ça c'est quelque chose qui va un petit
peu à l'encontre de deux de ce qu'on
pouvait dire tout sur et sur l'aspect
entre guillemets raciste de train alors
il reste une minute chacun edouard
husson
peut-être qu'on dira trempe filmé par
élu mardi sur ses quatre années à votre
avis on dira je crois premièrement j'y
reviens pardonnez-moi mais qu' il a
réalisé beaucoup sinon l'essentiel
il avait annoncé que ça soit là le
contrôle de l'immigration clandestine au
sud des états unis que ce soit le
soutien il c'est le président qui a été
le plus en faveur des pro-vie dépôt life
encore plus le régal
que ça soit un point de vue des
nominations de juges que ce soit aussi
avait annoncé dans le rapport de force
avec avec la chine
c'est là la première chose la deuxième
chose si effectivement il n'est pas
réélu mardi prochain on soulignera en
fait là quelque chose de cassé
ac c'est ans c'est là le refus des
démocrates de lui reconnaît quelques
légitimité ne soit depuis son élection
il y a eu une série d'accusations
il ya eu ensuite toute la campagne menée
contre lui à elle la mort de jazz floyd
et et et tout ça tout ça je montre comme
on le disait tout à l'heure
les etats unis très divisés alors ce qui
effectivement on peut nous séparer au
tour de ceux de cette table si j'ose
dire c'est le fait que moi je pense que
les démocrates porte une très lourde
responsabilité dans le refus de
reconnaître la légitimité de donald
trump et de le laisser gouverner mais ce
qui est impressionnant c'est qu'il a il
a fait beaucoup de choses par lui même
c'est un homme qui se nourrit de
l'adversité et d'ailleurs c'est la
raison pour laquelle je ne serai pas
complètement surpris s'il commençait un
deuxième mandat en janvier prochain
20le caisse après un tel plaidoyer du
mal à conclure je pense par exemple
qu'un homme qui qui nous dit qu'il
reconnaîtra peut-être pas le choix le
verdict des urnes si c'est pas dans de
telles conditions de telles conditions
net tout ça me pose un film un problème
est au fond très un peu pas trump le
tropisme ça existe et ça existera encore
après l'élection du 3 novembre et j'ai
peur de cette espèce de radicalisation
qu'on voit dans les deux parties on voi
la gauche du parti démocrate c'est pas
la gauche que je connaissais ya 30 ans
washington et la droite du parti
républicain
ce sont les vrais sécessionnistes à mon
avis cette minorité
cette future minorité blanche qui a des
problèmes d'identité et qui s'inquiète
peut être injuste juste titre
de l'avenir de cette communauté qui est
pour l'instant encore majoritaire je
pense que tout ça c'est un climat pas
comment dit c'est dangereux et c'est
dangereux encore une fois pour eux cette
merveilleuse idée qu'est l'amérique
selon moi je vous remercie tous les
trois d'avoir participé à ce débat et je
remercie aussi bas qu un élu nicolas
geissmann qui malheureusement dû nous
quitter et en plus vous avez été très
précis puisque maintenant la parole est
au président de la république merci
merci de nous avoir suivis et rendez
vous au prochain numéro
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
comment on peut expliquer que l'un
groupe énorme comme areva qui est
spécialisé puisse acheter des mines
inexploitables ça n'est pas expliqué